okay i'm going to give myself a
challenge that is probably way too much
for me
niah halsarin one of the young guns one
of the better
blitz players around and three zero
which we've already established is
too fast for me so i'm gonna at least
play the
the opening sort of quickly
oh it goes for this
that's a bit annoying right
oh it just goes g3
yeah these positions are probably just
better for white
so i'm going to go rook e8 if e5 bishop
g2
that doesn't work
oh he's renewing that particular threat
okay let me go queen c7
rook c8 and tuck the queen in on v8
so a6 that's part of the
part of the hedgehog right my q a try to
put some pressure on d4
and in general this position is a bit
better
but it's not that big a deal
normally my opposite my pawn should be
on e6 here
so i'm going to put it there as soon as
i can
and now you see the reason why i played
a6 earlier on
it's creating this uh hedgehog structure
as they call it
uh with all of these little spines
with the characteristic four pawns on
the
on the on the third rank and the
not including the pawn on on g6 which
is sometimes you another squares
queen e3 okay
i guess rook cd8 i want to go h6
just to take away the g5 square from his
queen
it seems very useful
and nothing
nothing that much going on
okay i'm gonna try d5 break in the
center
try and make something happen
if i would go 94.
yeah and also cd5 that was the sort of
trick i was hoping for
cd5 i would have gone for um
should i take yeah probably should take
one cd5 would have gone knight
c takes e4 and when whatever
bishop or knight he takes back with on
on um
on e4 i go i go
ed5 and i'm probably doing well
but he goes for this instead
not falling into falling into my plan
which is a bit disappointing for me
but i guess fairly normal as my opponent
is just an extremely strong player
okay i'm going to take an e5
don't see why that loses
oh my plan was to go
rook d2 and then
to play e3 but he has queen e3 attacking
the knights
that's a bit disappointing
okay let me
no probably just worse
and we're gonna get ourselves a bit of a
time scramble
the rook d6 is really annoying more
annoying than i
i hoped it would be
what do i do
king of seven maybe
yeah 96 i'm really
if i'm holding on it's my skin with
teeth
quick to seven
rookie five has he blended this
i hope so
oh i allow the check damn it damn it
damn it damn it
that was uncalled for that was so
uncalled for
so dumb like i knew that bishop c4 and
d66 was his idea
okay whatever